ranjana by goal is returning to her home
by boat to find out if there is anything
left of it there is not much to see
except water her home is in one of the
hundred and ninety-two villages in the
catchment area of Sardar Sarovar dam
which was built across the Narmada River
this year heavy rains almost filled the
reservoir and its back waters flooded
many villages in the central Indian
state of multiplied - our life savings
were spent in building this house now
how do we get the money to rebuild it
activists say at least 30,000 families
have not been compensated in full and
they have nowhere else to go
dams were described as temples of modern
India by the country's first Prime
Minister but have they delivered on the
promise of development not for those
whose homes have been submerged and
environmentalists say that damage they
caused and the costs outweigh any
benefits Sardar Sarovar dam seen as
symbolic of much of what is wrong with
large dams in India there are almost
6,000 of them and they have a lasting
social and environmental impact in every
village here there are not less than
2,000 big trees and if the trees get
submerged with the biomass the
greenhouse gas emissions come up
analysts say other countries in the
world are rethinking the value of dams
and conserving their rivers but India is
going in the opposite direction if you
look at last 4 decades since 1980 90% of
the additional vacation that has come
you know farmers have benefited from has
come for water has come from groundwater
so all these shows that the dams are not
delivering on the promise but the Indian
government see Sardar Sarovar dam as an
economic success story expected to ease
water problems and supply electricity -
for Indian states villagers say that's
come at a cost
what is that I'll go the whole village
has been destroyed
there is water as far as you can see
families have lived on the banks of the
Narmada for generations they worshiped
the river but now the waters have been
harnessed for the dam
they've lost their homes and their way
of life Archer Vora al-jazeera Mata
Pradesh India